hello hello are you there processing our
words we're late to starting this late
to the party very late to start Robert
and Vanessa oh my god Bernie Alvarado
you've already given us three Bernard
Bernie
you'd be very happy to know that your
main competition and the Democratic race
Biden has a message for all the black
supporters out there yeah yeah he's in
the position to let you know he's your
you're not black if you don't vote for
him if you are tracks is there proof
needed to put that out there now my
words his just saying this isn't a
political debate I'm trying to say it's
just facts well it's up so who's in the
chat right now it's gonna be a fun one
today my son thanks for the super chat
Rizzo normally so we got delegate scene
one puppy and I'm making storm Williams
he Niraj Erica Tuesday so scare 1999 I
love this show
hey thank you buddy that's really sweet
of you and all right so we got Sara so
if you guys can go ahead and hit that
like button that would mean a lot to us
when you say that ever really so we're
gonna say it to die if this video gets
250 likes I have another surprise super
choc deal will beginning of everyone's
super chats you know how we do if this
is your first time here thank you
welcome hit the like button even if you
don't like what you're watching already
do it anyway today's theme is gonna be
joy or sadness movies that make us cry
and so okay we already got a one person
fluorescent saying well oh my god oh my
god the rest in saying lovely bones yeah
that's a good one that's a good one and
then let's see here grave of the
fireflies the hell is that pay Megan
music we love you too oh wow we got so
many comments coming
chat let's see if revisiting any of
these will make us cry so before we get
to all the comments and the super chats
and whatever one that I'm gonna one that
made me I'm gonna go with the obvious
ones and as we do this live stream I'm
sure more will be discovered as time
goes on I think a great example of a
movie that you know is effective and by
the way I'll try to give like I'm gonna
try my best to communicate especially if
it's like ending scenes yes that way I
don't rule I'm gonna try not to ruin it
and do my absolute best but have you
seen The Green Mile no okay
well the Green Mile that I understand
it's a crier The Green Mile was ruined
for me before I ever watched it I knew
exactly what was gonna happen on
everything but I knew you know some big
character be moments that were gonna
happen and by the time it started
getting close to that big moment in the
movie I was watching it by myself so
embarrassing watching if I myself
knowing it was going to happen
everyone's already ruined it for me I
was like crying and like a Roman tears
just streaming down my face no don't let
it happen you know it's it's like that
effective ass thing where you know it's
gonna happen everyone's already
confirmed it for you but you really
don't want it to happen and yeah the
Green Mile was that's um that was the
one that really got me really got me
somebody somebody a lot of people will
be agreeing with you on that Green Mile
and Oh Mason in the chat saying onward
yeah I mean especially I said an Amira
in our review I cried like three times
watching that movie especially cuz of
like dealing with brothers dead father
you know I got some things I could
relate with that and that [ __ ] so I got
me very emotional Johnny got one you
wanna share I want a shout-out Josh Ren
right now because Singh Street is
definitely a movie with some emotional
notes in it definitely brought some
tears out of me and somebody else in the
chat name-checked
inside out which definitely made me cry
I know it's not your favorite Pixar
movie but that one especially by the end
or the you know the third act when it's
like this girl might just wind up
depressed forever I was really really
emotionally trying and depending on how
big the movie is like just how major a
movie is we might just let it slip like
for example let's see if I can find it
here Bernie Alvarado Thank You Bernie
Alvarado
for your contribution and the super chat
I love you what's your cat's name you
have your cat here in your profile they
call it dr. horrible movies that made me
cry of sadness
Titanic during the sinking at and the
end during the sink so it was like the
official sinking of the ship and TV
episodes that made me cry of joy my hero
academia season 3 episode 11 1 yeah that
I think I think we crowded that one we
reacted to every every single episode of
my hair Akademi right stone Pedro and I
think that one got us too I feel like it
did I feel like that was such a
harrowing finale that one the first the
very first episode of another very the
first episode of my hair Akademi that
made me cry for those who are my hero
academia fans that would be the one
where a zoo coup and midoriya we know
those December's Victoria lucuma Dorian
decagon oh yeah John who it's [ __ ]
him half fire half ice guy Otero
Todoroki
the one we're Todoroki and midoriya
fought each other for the first time
then you learn more about Totoro keys
backstory that was the that was the
first my hero episode that really got me
teary-eyed and Titanic for sure in the
like I saw that twice in the theaters
both times and that was another one that
got ruined for me I knew what would
happen to Jack and to wake up Jack the
[ __ ] ball a little baby man yeah man
that's the classic og everybody and
their mom
as crying yeah and Billy Zane's
performance Oh Oh don't was saying Joe
hahaha
don't be [ __ ] on the Billy Zane
alright that guy has made some quality
material okay yeah Thank You burning yes
what else do we got in this Chaplin
people here Joe Joe rabbit good call hey
Cryer Mr Bandt Lee shoes Jojo rabbit
oh yeah the shoes actually was closer to
the ending I forget one of the scenes
with the girl that who's locked in the
house
dude like don't wanna ruin it throughout
a wider that thread a lot of the third
act I was it's like the closer it got to
the end the more I was getting teary
eyed especially one like the reality of
the war all sets in and you know yeah
again don't want to give away too many
details but I definitely shed some both
tears for for that one
you know what scene was making me cry
we're gonna be in the inner geek them
for [ __ ] Schmoe down boy we were down
to give it a go so I was doing some
research on some things and what was
making me I was a couple of things I
just stumbled on when I was like doing
at just YouTube research done some
scenes to get familiar with people are
bringing up in the chat going through
crowd reactions of endgame when Black
Panther and Sheree and a coy a appear
through the portal and the crowds flip
in their [ __ ] and everyone starts
showing up for some reason the the
second time I watched the movie that
that was the scene that really got me
very like Tony's death yes I wanna yeah
but that scene in particular like that's
a tear of joy moment like overwhelmed
with joy and then the other thing
because I was what I remember all of
like um Wonder Woman's teammates names
chief not be Sameer
Charlie when that when they're going on
to no man's land and they do that
slow-motion shot a Wonder Woman
she takes off that's going up the ladder
every hours every [ __ ] time i watch
that scene I cannot hold back
I was quite teary theatres I looked over
at you and the theater and I saw you
doing this
yeah man while you were crying yeah I
was I was like let go girl doing you can
finally rest in peace Schneider cut
there's some very dirty Logan yeah
bringing up Logan definitely got some
tears during Logan
ooh Ryan baby our expert with Doctor Who
on patreon John definitely have cried
during some ducktor people love our
British accents that we do so please
humor them with your British accent by
reading rizzo gaming's super chat thank
you Thank You Ryan
hi guys inside-out Goodwill Hunting
Bridge to Terabithia the holiday 17
again Titanic Moulin Rouge amongst more
those are all do Moulin Rouge for sure
Oh 17 again for sure actually never saw
so I can enjoy Moulin Rouge that's a big
tearjerker right there and scene
yeah I've seen several times including
in the theaters who directed it Baz
Luhrmann thank God yeah we're gonna quiz
each other throughout Jim Broadbent in
it a whole bunch of people are a bridge
cetera haven't seen Bridge to Terabithia
nope I was always make for the best live
streams I'm gonna focus on the ones I
haven't seen Good Will Hunting datas the
first time I saw the Good Will Hunting
scene of of it's not your fault oh yeah
was actually what Family Guy parodied it
I didn't know what they were doing oh
and Brian Owen Stewie it's Brian saying
the Stewie such a fault hey back off man
I didn't know what they were doing so
thought it was funny and then eventually
when I watch go bowhunting I quickly
flashed the Family Guy but I was so in
the moment and yeah that moment really
did I love those kind of tears though
those kind of like I don't really cry
too often at death scenes it's more of
like those kind of moving emotional
scenes when someone's coming to like a
realization or something beautiful or
loved or heroic like I can cry like a
romantic comedy or something like in the
office when Jim proposed to Pam oh yeah
I was a mess for Norwood Chandler
proposes the Monica a good call there
man John in mr. Alexander Edward
Scissorhands when Winona Ryder is
dancing in the snow I wonder why that
was so moving for you you know I I can
sort of understand there's something I
don't know if I've ever cried during it
but there is something weirdly moving
about that sequence in Sleepy Hollow
where little Ichabod and his mom liked
it's that interlude where his mom is
dancing and for a moment it's fine and
like there's something oddly beautiful
in that Tim Burton II moment that I feel
like kind of carries over into
whatever's at the DNA of that scene with
OneNote it it's ironic because it's Tim
Burton's career that's making me cry
through the looking-glass said that if
you're black and you're vote for Trump
you're not really black if you're not up
and you're not black but no one matter
lack mm a king in the chat Marley & Me
ah that is a any movie that like stars a
dog or animal of some kind that's not
cats and dogs yeah make its making me as
reminded me of the was the [ __ ] Will
Smith movie my god I'm this it's days
like this when I have a showdown match
coming up I'm worried I'm brain fart I
think I did get teary-eyed during I am
Legend yes Sam
seamless Sam dog yeah hmm thanks John if
only those worthy Rock ado thank you
buddy
watching Logan watch Logan again last
night and that was hmm apps
literally man daddy dad still was kind
of unsure why she
x-23 Laura Laura Laura Laura
bye Laura who is calling calling him
like did she really view him as dad or
was it just in his dying moments that
she was realizing he was dad in his
dying knives and Logan - case you guys
didn't see it I'm sorry Runa for you but
Logan dies in his dying moments she
realized how you know stem cell and
cloning works and really theirs based
off his genes and thus decided to accept
him as her father Wow John that's a
great call dude someone cried during
green book and Batman Begins a dogs /
Batman Begins huh that was 43 and four
that's a good call I got point this out
so scourge a knight thank you buddy for
your super chat by the way Schindler's
List finale when he's giving the speech
and he's saying I could have saved more
I actually haven't seen Schindler's
lists from beginning to end I've only
seen like the last half hour okay I
caught that when they randomly aired it
I think on NBC many many years ago okay
and yes I did get teary eyed yeah that
is I feel like that's one more like if
you aren't affected you have some kind
of titanium emotional spectrum I mean
it's it's it's interesting to point [ __ ]
like that out like with Schindler's List
where you can just stumble upon a scene
and that's a good like in the Patriot
Mel Gibson directed by Roland Emmerich
co-starring gregory smith and when
there's there's a death scene in the
movie with the character and Mel Gibson
has a breakdown moment he breaks the
[ __ ] down and I walked into the theater
we were theater house theater hop boom
and my dad which you just can't do
anymore because everything's reserve
seating but I was theater hopping with
my Tim it was theater I feed her hop
into the patriot and like ten minutes
before this death scene occurred I came
across the scene and it's like the movie
has like 40 minutes left or something
like that and yeah like I was I was so
moved
I started crime I have no real
investment in this characters might just
showed
yeah I'm very much moved by oh okay yeah
okay I've seen a few people shouting out
up which is like the go to Pixar crier
to Kristen yeah you said it John lone
survivor that's what I wasn't expecting
to see that's alright Oh before people
get mad at us I think we missed a couple
super chats what we got to do it John so
I do that nope I do like that guy
alright so who do we got here oh it was
so miss one from Soul scourge eh oh just
got Forrest Gump ruined for me that's my
fault I haven't seen Forrest Gump I mean
there's a lot more to it alright so
Jenny's gravestone update on junior okay
I don't know what he's talking about
there the Forrest Gump tear you up
you know I saw it I've been seeing it
since I was a child and so I think
because of that no not really but you
know if I I wonder if I would had I seen
it you know at this age or something
like that you know it's like yeah I grew
up on that movie and so like it's kind
of second nature in a way huh but if I
watch it's been a long time since I've
seen it so I feel like at this stage of
my life I might be inclined to cry
during various moments of that movie
there's a lot of heavy stuff in there
well if we're gonna if I'm gonna get
Forrest Gump room for me I'm glad it's
in the form of a super chat Travis oh
thank you for such a big contribution
there dude you really appreciate the
support Travis Austin he says love this
channel and you're handsome sexy faces
oh you're the hazard Zach see what
actually I can see from this tiny tiny
guy I hear that you got a bitchin bod
movies that make me cry of the top of my
head winDriver yeah there's an Indian
character in there at the end that made
me really talking with jeremy renner
that got to me yeah factory girl
imaginary heroes rabbit holes name of
you got some interesting aspects here I
think pigs yeah I thought Cinnabon I
thought everyone was gonna say you know
endgame
there's a great big suit random Andy's
Channel Oh a live chat I'm at another
live chat oh well thanks for your super
chat dude believe that live chat and get
over here
and just hang out with us random Annie's
channels where your priorities bruh but
I appreciate you dude
appreciate you being here all the man
Brendan V is in the chat man what's up
let's see what everyone else in the chat
saying currently the mist the missed
such a letdown oh boy
there's a who else the short term 12 the
big sick ending yes Jesse poop thanks
for being here in the chat buddy
pursuit of happiness as a crier pursuit
of happiness
is like the best tears ever yeah yeah
inspiringly harrowing you my fate like
sometimes like the tears that really get
me or when a character's trying not to
cry cus so when will uh I mean okay
there's a part in movie I don't know if
anyone's seen it I mean it's based on it
I think like a lot of people knew this
story before he came out about this guy
who was broke and then landed
successfully I heard and then sure I'm
like I know where the movies gonna go so
there's a scene in the in the movie and
if you guys have seen you'll know I'm
talking about where Will Smith is given
an offer at a company and he's worked
his ass off here so I guys I think I
would a lot of people go to with that
film of what makes them cry is the
bathroom scene with him and Jayden yeah
when he's happening to you know make
life fun with imagination when really
they're living in a hellhole they're
homeless you know like that's that's
where a lot of people go to with that
but the scene that always gets me is
towards the end when he gets a job offer
he's like he's called my god it's
starting to happen to me right now he's
not gonna happen on this footing that's
the challenge today don't cry it's not
gonna happen but you know what I did
once upon a time is I literally The Lion
King
scene where Simba is like alone in the
gorge and Mufasa is dead and he's like
calling out to anybody like for whatever
reason that scene was stuck in my head
and I recited it a few times to the
point that I started to cry just because
of how sad the memory of that scene made
me feel it's funny because there's like
there's this scene in Sleepless in
Seattle where there's this uh I forget
the character's name there's this woman
who's retelling the story of a movie to
Tom Hanks and she's his monologue in the
whole movie she started to cry as she
said it's like a really funny scene
because of how ridiculous it is that
she's like just retelling a movie and
she's starting to cry about how moved
move she was and I find that that
happens to me now more than ever I might
be like replaying a scene in my head and
I'll just start like tearing up about it
you know but yeah I don't know
see the thing is okay people might be
asking why this theme today not just
it's like a fun one to go over but I I
feel like the stigma towards crying has
slowly been going especially for men
like the distinguished usually directed
at men everybody needs to cry sometime
but I used to be on a lot of medication
and stop my crying before and before I
was a run-time was like getting off my
medication one thing that and this isn't
like the only solution to getting off
medication I'm just saying that like one
thing that I read about was how you know
allowing yourself to cry can actually be
more beneficial and more powerful than
most antidepressants and I feel like it
just helps with not repressing or
whatever so for the men who are watching
today don't be afraid to cry and I've
met I've still met those men today who
are like yeah I never crash don't cry
try I don't know how to yeah watch the
gray that's a good men crying absolutely
the end of Toy Story 3 Toy Story 4 a
Tanner and the chest and toys 3 or 3 Toy
Story 4 it got me more than Toy Story 3
if I'm being honest yeah I think I'll go
down there that road with y'all Toy
Story 3 especially with like the we can
pass on this little girl yes you know
that that definitely got me at the
moment for show I love I love the chat
especially the Erica starting it in the
chat room let men cry yes
that men cry you know what Louis cross
is bascomb it'd work you know what I
hear more than ever is people going you
know like I feel like I need to cry and
I just can't like I don't know it's like
a blocked up or something you know yeah
so that's a real thing and it needs
fixing it's going to walk walk it off
walk off the tears man walk off the
tears that's sodium into my body all
right Rizzo gaming thank you again for
another super chapter dude
appreciate it buddy all right you did
the British accent last time I'm gonna
show you how to properly sorry yeah and
the people from the UK always appreciate
this
Lord of the Rings the green moil
lovely bounds Shawshank twelve years a
slave
yeah the oil giant that thumri in the
comments waiting for way for okay no
complaints so far dragon heart yes
Toy Story 3 sure how'd it trying yo
dragon sure Dead Poets nor Dead Poets
Society just if you just see that just
if you find a dead poet at a local
coffee crying over it's a sad thing to
say it is is a dead poet yeah die sorry
Ryan
sweep your chimney all will all will
yeah those are some great pics mm-hmm 12
years of slave my god that's a heavy
film yeah actually speaking of
recounting a story in one's head and
then crying about it
Hacksaw ridge if you go to my review for
that I'm talking about something in that
movie and you could see if he's starting
to tear up just talking about you wanna
see Greg tear up during a review go
watch the call me by the name review
speaking of which I got a great one
actually one of the biggest impressions
of film has left on me via tears was
Fruitvale station because like the whole
first hour so that movie was not what I
expected I was like oh wow this is so
vibrant and full of life and energetic
and then
and then the the moment of the movie we
all know is coming comes and like for
the whole last 2025 minutes I was just
non-stop tears like and I watched that
at the old apartment by myself and like
you know you're never as expressive by
yourself as you are with people or
whatever but I I was just like full
words for that movie there's a lot of
pics here for the [ __ ] Marley & Me
movie dude if you guys are just tuning
in with me if you'd hit that like button
yeah it's up to 250 Dillon winter thanks
for being in the chat buddy
Dillon Diego Lasley neato rad Fruitvale
okay yeah there's some love for
Fruitvale station John Mike Jones is her
that's another great call I'd add that
mote that movies one that like hits me
yeah yeah I mean III identified a lot
with that movie you you did with
Theodore Twombly you identified with her
now with her with him identify with him
yeah data computer well I don't know
part of it you start you start that's
right I identified with the part where
you get a surrogate to make you know
your computer girlfriend's body you know
a reality but other than that I couldn't
really get into too many chat rooms with
a bunch of naked chicks are thinking
that you're actually your girlfriend's
John that's right is that it that's what
I took away from them because this guy
who loves web oh god yeah Oh in the chat
jack is saying um a fast and furious 7
oh yeah yeah oh my god yet so you hear
Wiz Khalifa come on that's absolutely
true
Brendan Vee thank you so much dude
Brendan be John do your stereotypical
gay guy voice he likes it Toy Story 2
Meet the Robinsons and wala he's the one
who wants it hi story what do you think
he shot me and now I got a split the
difference here meat though Robin thin
Walli God actually yeah Wally when I
hadn't seen it since it came out in the
theaters I saw it again last right when
Disney Plus came out Olivia my female
girlfriend it's important to specify
that before people started thinking
otherwise yeah about me she she wanted
to watch it and yeah this time
rewatching it especially towards the end
when Eva's really worried about Wally
what she thinks
Wally might be deceased Mina a wreck
scene right there actually an
interesting way to earn brownie points
and my girlfriend is if I cry at
something she wants to watch oh nothing
she loves I mean I'm moved by it then
and on that into it it does wonders for
our relationship nice turning me into a
[ __ ] [ __ ] is what she's don't tell
anybody on you don't worry Thank You
Brandon Vee Nicolas nuñez Alvarez are
you talking about Jet Li's fearless did
you cry see I'm Jet Li's fearless or is
there a different fearless Robert in the
chat is bringing up the movie click and
click is such an interesting movie to me
because it it's like it's an Adam
Sandler sci-fi comedy but every time I
hear about it it's always about the
emotion no one ever tells me about the
funny [ __ ] from click everyone only
tells me about like how they cried they
click I have you seen it no and I've not
ever heard that part have you heard how
funny it is I've heard it was I know
people who liked it and thought it was
funny so like they didn't go out of
their way to tell me how funny it was
but they're like yeah I like the movies
funny but I did not know it was like a
tearjerker - oh it is yeah yeah I gotta
watch it now I gotta go cry it takes
this like really dark turn towards the
end of the movie ok yeah I props to them
for doing that I did makes me that much
more interested than I was before
Niraj Krishna
nice dude Toy Story 3 Toy Story 3 is a
common theme here a star is born oh my
god yes my favorite yes yes but which
put so many parts to cry about three
specific parts and a star is born and
the land when I rewatched it same exact
three moments copy what I mean [ __ ] what
that scene when [ __ ] he brings Lady
gaga
on stage yeah that is one of the most
moving scenes and like that was a scene
that the more I kept going I think I was
oh god I was wreck ah Rekha dil oh good
call I was gonna name check 1917 at some
point but that that ISM is a movie that
made me cry for sure and I think it
highlighted something is like I I do am
often I am often moved over stories
where people are like exerting way past
their limit to try and achieve some sort
of goal and like the amount of just
harrowing emotion that especially in the
second half of the movie after a certain
specific point I won't spoil that at
George Mackay like has to carry and show
like there were multiple times where I
teared up or or cried during that movie
in multiple screenings really yeah man
like you know it's weird it's like for
as much as any cried that man
and I don't blame you it's weird it's
one of those movies where I think
there's a lot to debate about you know
the form versus the content and all that
but yeah there's just something about
the body language and the aura of that
movie that really affected me each time
I saw it really mm-hmm
that's pretty surprising yeah yeah yeah
I was a little surprised myself you know
they're they're seen a lot of oh oh oh
no I missed it missed it John I missed
it life is beautiful
alright guys before people get mad at us
being like you're skipping super Jets we
can't make your accent made me cry what
do you mean my accent made you cry
I'll have why you main Jambo so you
generally hide this impression from the
youkai I really love the advice of
punching the tears off your face that
manly way to go do some catch-up here oh
my god that's let's let's eat some
ketchup all right okay John John I've
done [ __ ] up the chat tell another
movie I cried at oh yeah there's a movie
called the way way back that is a
coming-of-age movie that I saw in the
theater I walked out of the theater with
tears on my face I walked right back in
the theater and I saw it again and that
was the most recent time I can remember
like going to a movie and then
immediately watching it like really yeah
yeah it was partly just to do with like
the time in place in which it came out
and you know I was going through some
stuff at the time so it's a
coming-of-age story and and you know
there were relevant themes involved but
yeah that movie affected me quite quite
quite a bit in a way I wasn't expecting
why won't it show I have this photo of
Mel Gibson and Colin Farrell up and it's
not showing here I can fix it I know
what I did
god dammit John uh here we'll just stop
this little screen fiction everyone's
leaving this the live stream now that's
what you guys will see right yes let men
cry let men cry crazy Kyle should play
the son of Mel Gibson Colin Farrell
should be in the reboot of Lethal Weapon
bits get back that petition going it's
the time now's the time
god I'm trying to see what else you know
what's funny is like I love Ryan Gosling
but none of his movies I think I've
actually made me tear up
really Blue Valentine I'm wrong about
that is like a heart destroy really
alright so playing some catch up here
porch Mimi M hey Mimi thank you so much
you doing dear portrait of a lady on
fire I need to see that
room with Tommy Wiseau yam brie Larson
Fruitvale station with I don't have a
joke and Detroit and pull at the end
also princess in the frog Ray's love to
Evangeline you'll princess in the frog
still the one I haven't seen I like that
movie a lot you should watch it John
you have officially gotten rid of your
racist card that's right that's the way
to do it you watch The Princess and the
Frog because that one draws the children
in as well as the other I'm waiting for
that day to come and you're finally
starving rice I are finally not a racist
anymore I mean I'm not all white anymore
I will say guys over here to the new the
stream welcome to the chaos the fact
that there's a [ __ ] ton of graphics on
it screech add a charm is that these are
off accompanied yeah we would used to
stress out about how like [ __ ] uh
like how unprofessional this look and we
realized was that
it's about being charmingly
unprofessional let men cry everyone
chanted in the chat let men cry oh let
men cry cry gene Jeter what's up buddy
guys go check out his channel
quarantined chill number three and if
you don't want to just listen but look
at some visuals some beautiful woman on
the string hmm the ending of the pursuit
of happiness was full of emotion true
yes it was now when you just say full of
emotions that could be a wide variety
full anger full of like anger and lust
confusion I did not cry angry lusty
confused I didn't cry thank you dick you
chat heard Lemongrab yeah I didn't cry
but my girlfriend at the time did I was
touched that she was touched and then
eventually she let me touch her because
she was being vulnerable I have been
talking in my ear me look like a
sensitive guy pretty sure I got her well
that's touching and then she broke up
with me and now she's my ex girl
yeah I was gonna say I'm sorry to hear
that oh no are you gonna get them back
bring back the Mel bring back the Melvin
Colin Farrell and then who else we got
Erica Tuesday she's holding down the
chat for us in so many ways right now
moderating Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind thank you for your satanic
chat here 666 it's turtle sunshine of
the spotless - a movie I can no longer
watch with the soundtrack I can no
longer listen to even thinking about it
gets to me Wow emotional movie well now
erica is opening up a fun question for
me to throw to you guys in the chat is
there a movie that was just so emotional
or so triggering well let's like it was
so emotionally overwhelming that you
just can't watch it again because of how
much that movie just gets to you yeah
don't go with the trigger trigger your
PTSD that's a good question though I
mean like anything affected you so much
that it it literally is difficult to
watch again yeah I don't know if I have
one of those honestly Robert and the
chat is saying agent Cody Banks - yeah I
cried because they released that The
Pianist we're just watching what he went
through it was just depressing alright
good call mark Marley and Me actually I
met at Marley I've met a few people who
said that for Marley and me way too
emotional Schindler's List is another
one for sure
some of the ones we've already brought
up some huh Jack's comment in the chat
is spider-man far from home trailer
those that fit to answer Greg's question
Taylor Celeste and Jesse forever do you
know what that movie's I've heard of it
and I if I think hard enough could
probably maybe remember some casting but
I've not seen it Good Will Hunting do
you have a movie that was just too
emotional for you that you just couldn't
say you can't revisit the best I can
gather is it would probably be it would
the only movie I can think of that like
really if me in such a way that it's
like I don't know when the next time I
be like I gotta watch this movie but you
know zero dark thirty did a number on me
and I don't know if I would be keen to
revisit it because you know that that
movie rattled my nerves in a weird way
dude
reviewing zero dark thirty with John
when this channel was first getting
started was such a hard experience cuz
he just could not communicate that day
yeah I couldn't I don't know why it was
weird like what's the big deal just cuz
of how accurate it feels just about how
horrible acts because of how harrowing
and how close to home and all yeah I
know it did yeah you know it's weird I
got I got one I got one
what was it I don't know if it was like
too emotional I wouldn't revisit it but
there was a time where I was like very
anal and III got this one which
housekeys when they were brothers Dania
pointed out does that make me look like
a bad guy say no I think as you mention
a time and place marker so all at a ball
it's like alright good who not getting
cancelled today boys and girls or what
yogurt today so they said that then when
they watch a screening of bound with a
like a gay and lesbian crowd that they
were that the crowd was so moved that
they couldn't ever watch the movie again
because nothing could top that
experience so I had that experience with
a movie like not one I maybe was when I
watched that I was so moved by I was so
moved by it that I was like I'm never
gonna watch this again until I've almost
forgotten everything about it that way I
can really like try to replicate that
level of emotional experience now the
reason I haven't watched it again since
it came out more than a decade ago is
because of how much hate the movie has
received and how it is criticized as
being a movie that did not deserve to
win Best Picture
I'm like well now I'm kind of afraid to
go back and like it
I did cry during this movie too though
and that is the movie crash not the
David Cronenberg crash about fetish
fetish II stuff no it's it's I mean yeah
I saw it when I was like 15 or something
so maybe with a more mature mind I won't
like it as much but but at the time it
was so emotional for me maybe it was
meant for fifteen-year-old kids I tell
me racism's wrong little boy it's true
it is Green books they're for the books
they're for that now too
[Laughter]
I got some emotions during that
experience blind some people are saying
that once I decide Brokeback Mountain
from L be in the chat is saying that the
Santa Claus huh intense displays of
kindness also get me so to that tone and
I'm gonna mismatch the titles and I need
to see the documentary but a beautiful
day in the neighborhood definitely you
know Tom Hanks Mister Rogers all that
kind understanding well you know
benevolence really just yeah overwhelms
me well as a movie that made I'm one
that really mean beautiful day in the
neighborhood did make me cry but won't
you be my neighbor
I guess I've talked about this on a live
stream before like that had a I didn't
know anything about mr. Rogers I didn't
grow up on his show like I was familiar
with the like the bits of hello neighbor
like that bit but within the documentary
there's a little on a documentary it's
like explores whole life yeah and when
there's where he's like speaking of
Congress or something about trying to
make sure the show can stay on PBS and
fighting for why that moment like I was
crying and my girlfriend wasn't she's
like she called you a [ __ ] she turned
to me and said I feel so goofy whatever
I told the story she turned to me as
he's like are you crying and then I
wouldn't
I'm with you I'm with you I really want
to watch that documentary soon Carter
we're going you know us we go through
the super chat slowly we'll get I'm sure
we'll get see well we'll do a quick
recap of all them to make sure that we
that we got see that we got it okay I've
seen Philadelphia I've seen Million
Dollar Baby
oh it's you I feel like that movie
hasn't aged in terms of like public love
and reception all that great but that
definitely got me choked up so scared so
so sad 1999 yeah uh scared the Tyrell
corporation name that movie oh it's it's
a Blade Runner yeah took me a second I
was like it's not Waylon dancing that's
alien castaway Wilson and letting go of
his fiancee those are three separate
movies that he's listed there castaway
the movie Wilson and the movie I love
it's really hard all those 90 minutes
where he lets go farting comedy who is
like surprisingly emotional in the night
right no the Wilson's and before that
III see here I am
before that you also said inside out
Bing bong scene oh yeah and poor Bing
bong more richard kind there should be
like a smoking a bong scene that's like
really emotional you know the you know
you're trying to smoke a bong while
you're crying not easy there's good you
know what if no one's written it yet one
of us is gonna have yeah alright needs
to be I'm gonna go through here really
quick to make sure a lot I miss Carter
Lovejoy's because we love Carter and I
don't want to disappoint we did not
we're just going in order mmm-hmm the
good dinosaur yeah jasmine good call the
good dinosaur that you know a movie gets
a lot of flack for being like the less
than movie but I'd love that I really
love that film and I I was very
emotional during that yeah it was there
there are things I don't love especially
but there are things I think are
particularly effective about it so I'm a
little mixed on but I think there's some
good stuff in there oh my god shouts out
to Peter in the chat he is saying that
the Fox and the Hound [ __ ] yeah
when she has to let copper know Todd
just let Todd go isn't name of my cat's
tonic copper two of two of our cats
it's just let Todd go on your inner
monologue like it's some [ __ ] anime
Oh God mm-hmm are you all ready you go
in there try not to I could see your
eyes awakening that's a movie I actually
need to see I need to see awakenings for
sure but I yeah I've heard that's a very
emotional film also uh yeah Connor
Williams Robert De Niro that's like um
I'm a vegetable I'm a [ __ ] vegetable
watch this movie because I'm gonna want
that the entire time because uh Penny
Marshall who made it awakenings is the
that's Robert De Niro and Robin Williams
he not a comedy at all um Robin will his
daughter if it's based on true story
Robin Williams is there like a different
word than vegetable is that like an
offensive term that I'm just not
realizing has no brain power right you
get that you get the point of getting
yeah he's either brain damaged or brain
dead and then they start doing they
figured out it's based on true story of
how to like help bringing bring him back
to normalcy it's very beautiful film and
yeah that was a DeNiro denominator for
that movie very good he's a good actor
apparently Thank You Jude never thought
I always I always viewed him as like a
Taylor Lautner or something Connor Brown
good call as well I did cry during
Rocket Man or sure as also that I think
any well done tale of somebody learning
how to actually accept and love
themselves those those get to me either
there are so many people in this
chat right now how to train your dragon
to good culture there's so many people
in this chat that are pointing out
clique people I know that are just
chiming in all right watch click all
right it's not most people talk about
how sad it is about funny secret drama I
had no idea like there are some funny
scenes but it's that's not the point
that's not the point
yeah the point is like there's a bunch
of like yeah man you gotta watch click
hold on say how many likes are we are it
it doesn't matter okay well check it out
later guys if you're new hit the like
button we're gonna check this at the one
hour mark good no locker room them big
fish hey Lisa Marie deke economist
makers garage near marsh Ford vs.
Ferrari and a league of their own
there's no crying in baseball ha the
reference reference arise you know if
you cried there is crying in watching
cinema so you have the loophole there I
feel like for view Ferrari did make me
tear up at one point but I can't
remember what it was it wasn't the
ending it wasn't quite the ending I
think it had something to do with I'm
trying to think now I feel like it was
most of the way through the movie and I
feel like it had something to do with
him actually like with Matt Damon and
and Christian Bale and like they're
succeeding outside of everything else
like something he gets his perfect lap
or something like that yeah although I I
do gotta say the scene where Matt Damon
at the very very end comes and sees his
kid and you know waves to the wife
across that got me at least misty for
sure me out I would love to go back and
pinpoint the moment yeah must be through
it and then we'll speak Ford there
that's when I cried oh I'm crying now
I'm crying yes all right
like I like what you're bringing up here
Thanks Thank You Niraj by the way and
Jeff West jr. thank you buddy look at
that it's all nail goddamn the inception
hallway fight always makes me cry tears
of joy it just reminds me of being a kid
scene movie magic for the first time you
know
I love I love your answer here it's a
great way to diversify this just a
little bit but by the way really fast
Armageddon for sure there's space
dementia there's a there are certain I'm
having a hard time recalling it right
now really I'm thinking of my brother of
when he reacted to cry he reacted to the
top gun trailer and he was so moved by
the by the experience of that trailer or
not because he's like this top gun
fanatic but what they've accomplished at
filmmaking and what a like here just so
moved by it that he started crying and
like what is there anything in the chat
that you guys can think of works just
like movie magic on display not
necessarily like a death or you know a
big like love see whatever just
something that was like it was just such
pure cinema magic that it actually got
you emotional can you guys think of
anything because that's a good call with
like the inception hallway if I you know
that's a great hall and well I think
weirdly it's another Nolan film but for
me I think even though I don't
necessarily view interstellar as a
perfect film all the way across the
board when I saw that in IMAX and
theater and all that and and I was
surrounded by the scope and the scale
and the spectacle I was pretty moved by
that alone because in that moment i sat
there going I bet this is probably as
close as I'll get right now to feeling
what people might have felt seeing 2001
for the first time in a theatre and so
yeah that movie you know in a slightly
different context move me a similar way
rush like wow this is beautiful
yeah well in the chat we're getting
Titanic clinic let's end games final
battle yeah I think end game I think
that epic battle of end game does
qualify as that there is a movie magic
oh yeah is there something about it that
because that's that end game final
battle is working on a couple of levels
where you have because yeah you're moved
by the fact that they're back we all
expected them to come back you're moved
by the moment but it is also at least
for me this thing of oh wow the the joy
and celebration of the culmination truly
is felt and here and so there is a movie
magic
McKenna I really because of the
visual like achievement but more of the
build-up achievement you know done with
that so yeah I would say that so a gay
brown the Chastain to score an endgame
Wonder Woman no-man's land yeah that's
good call good you know
shambo's just called out Jack Frost with
Michael yeah I mean which one makes you
cry more though Jack Frost with Michael
Keaton or Jack Frost the evil snowman
slash removing DCF what's up DCF Ron
various seven of course that last see of
course we talked about that bohemian
endgame Oh bohemian endgame that was at
the end help Freddy defeat and all the
other bands who played live a to show up
as well which part of Bohemian Rhapsody
did you cry out I wanted no one that was
funny that was a knows with confusion
you cry which the King Kong did you cry
during Amina 1996 Coco Alberto or bina
called out Coco and that's a good call
for Coco and Secretariat oh I don't know
if I cried but I'm happy somebody
remembers them whoo okay Joel in the
chat saying coach Carter so I mean what
about what about inspirational movies
movies that are just so inspiring that
they made you know that's a that's a
really good question that's a that's a
bit more of a humdinger it's a new one
well I think that's where that no man
Lansing and Wonder Woman is so effective
because it's inspiring
mmm-hmm you just might it is V scene
here's a classic man cry scene and I
want to know if you have or do cry
during it the T two thumbs up
six into the metal do you cry when he
knows why you cry I don't cry I cry and
leading up wondering before he's in the
lava okay by the thumbs up now who's not
really a big like to someone in the
bigger moment like the big part is I now
know why you cry like Terminator it's
like general understand human emotion
now yeah yeah like that's the big tear
part that counts but that probably when
I was a kid you know yeah
now whenever I go in the pool I do
[Music]
Yodas death okay we're out of here meet
Joe Black varsity blues that's a that's
one that is inspiring enough to make
someone cry Remember the Titans I was I
I know there's a scene in there that's
like so inspiring me tear up
yeah into the spider-verse oh that is
his movie magic moving stuff honey boy
man I feel like I would cry during
homeward bound JJ Pitts good call I
definitely cried as a youth animal movie
I haven't seen Marley & Me but animal
movies are good Criers Jon Cryer hmm
Kirsten the chat saying okay I bring it
up where dreams may come from the scene
where they are the scene where dreams
may come from the scene where they are
floating in the sky with angels and
mermaids the idea of how your dreams
become true the beauty of dreams oh
that's an inspiring movie magic moments
tearjerker chasing the chata Saint
Christopher Nolan the Dark Knight the
two scenes with Joker and the Batman car
chase yeah i weirdly get a little bit of
motion like I get it like I'm just so
moved by how like incredible of an
action see that assails that yeah good
call great call some things sometimes
there's nothing more moving than just
seeing somebody execute with such
panache yeah let's see here purrs right
Rizzo gaming what's up there you are
again buddy I've heard I haven't seen
hurts of being a wallflower always
really gets me he says Perks of Being a
Wallflower always really
but its perks of being a wall cause it's
such a like a positive title that I
imagine it's probably a very emotional
movie then yeah I mean it's one of those
you know teen coming-of-age stories and
stuff I remember people would read it
like the book was really popular I think
when I was in high school or something
like that and then yeah the movie I'm
just like oh yeah there's gonna be some
broken heartedness probably there's
gonna be some outcast Ness and there's
gonna be some emotion 99% of the time if
there's a movie that has this like super
positive title that means it's a very I
don't like emotional hard drama don't go
watch happiness let's not forget
seriously the 99 happiness pursuit of
happiness there's a movie with Kirsten
Dunst and and Ryan Gosling about like a
terrible couple based on a true story
couple all good things
yeah it's not about all good it's always
like really sad [ __ ] happy titles or
titles with the word honor or yeah there
you go
you guys get it you guys get it thank
you Thank You Ryan ooh we got a new
person here thank you oh man thank you
Peter Peter Grindle oh my god you have
an intimidating ass [ __ ] face
dude you you you look awesome you look
like a guy who's trying mess with you
you look like a guy who someone said are
you gonna cry and you're like I'm never
and I can't cry now on I'm never crying
yeah I have a condition it's called
being a badass that's how we encourage
other men to cry till they cry and then
we treat them like we're doing them a
favor I'm sorry I'm just [ __ ] you out
of luck buddy I'm from Norway don't tell
me you guys didn't cry when the Fox in
the Fox and the Hound was left oh my god
yeah I'm just talking about that yeah
absolutely
oh thank you for your major super chat
see yeah that I mean even in the end
with a copper and an Tod having a
showdown with each other some real sad
[ __ ]
dude boxing the hounds probably the
likely of the Animated Classics before
Pixar Fox in the Hound is definitely the
one that has always consistently got me
the most emotional hmm hey I mean you
have one what is it
Dumbo Pinocchio has Cinderella or
Cinderella Cinderella the Disney besides
the Lion King not sure if any of the
classic Disney's made me weep bitter
tears I'm just I'm just so obsessed with
your profile I know but you're like you
have like this beautiful bone structure
but also you have this piercing look in
your eyes like I want to look at you but
I'm also not gonna lie the way I read
your comment based off of your face here
is I'm from Norway don't tell me you
guys didn't cry nobody makes me [ __ ] my
[Music]
David Sousa I am a bad person I need to
see moonlight still moonlight Oh Return
of the King I am the only person I think
in the world who really does like the
hobbits on the bed scene I'm like
they're all back together they're so
happy give it to the let them have it
god but that's anyway that's a detour
has the size I know nobody can and I'm
the only one who's like I don't know
there happens a little too over-the-top
into heavenly for me it's a little it's
a little ethereal yeah but I do cry when
Aragorn is like no we we bow to you that
is not a very sad thing except the man
in our screening who yawns several times
at the endings but you know [ __ ] that
guy yeah I had to pee right when what's
the spot Sheba what's she loves Shelob
[ __ ] oh my god
Shelob the spider shows up at the end
like right around that time like there's
like two and a half hours that movie
left I was already like and I need to
start right then and there as a [ __ ] and
you go to the bathroom and then it just
kept getting worse that was that was the
Last Samurai for me oh man
Bambi goddamn be is a crier if you
haven't hit that like button make sure
to hit that like button Bambi is more OG
crier that is an OG cry movie a secret
life of walter mitty huh
oh I've read the story I can see why it
would make you cry for sure
Aladdin what I hadn't made you cry hmm
all right let's see here coo coo now we
sit in silence yes we we refresh the
stream we take a moment to observe all
that has come before us yeah I've seen
the bug ulis man did you cry one of one
of Morgan Freeman's things on his bucket
list is cry for the first time I'm 89
years old that I haven't cried such a
man yeah the scene is he one of his
goals is to cry tears of joy or tears of
laughter oh he does it's a beautiful
thing Oh dah be in a [ __ ] uh Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows yeah
that's a sad one have you seen that yet
no are you saying yeah because I know it
you can't say yeah if you haven't seen
it during the book time and guys I don't
know if you know this but there's a
Schneider ACOG coming out yeah whoa
let's see here uh Brendan V forgot Logan
and find out although I try to block out
Logan just it's one of those movies
that's too sad Brendan V man yeah I
agree with you on half of this I love
Logan inside-out I don't know I mean
maybe if i rewatch i cried at the end
but she's like [ __ ] talking
to the god this is one of the rarest
livestreams by the way where we've had a
theme and we're an hour in and we're
still on it on that beer and we haven't
brought it out it's like there's not
like types of media or anything yeah Oh
an ISA has entered the chat what's up
girl oh you wouldn't be here today
Oh cow she's on he's working right now
but it's on a break
literally we're usually like on a whole
bunch of different directions and
tangents by this point and the chat has
taken over into something else so yeah
we're still happy with us we can go on a
tangent with the Schneider forgot Logan
and inside out oh well dude you know
it's okay to feel that don't be afraid
to feel your feelings some if you if you
ever feel a little bit blocked up maybe
watching Logan would be good for you
just saying for a laxative have it on
your disposal and then Carter after
forty minutes we've finally made it to
your super chat buddy Carter Lovejoy
Thank You Karger I'm Titanic made me cry
when I was nine Forrest Gump made me cry
when I was sixteen so which one's sadder
Logan made me cry when I was 22 you
solve for X is this how you remember
your years or what you did that so what
was life for you like when you were 16 I
cried it for a cub and that was the
whole year uh-huh John you got a yes and
faster yes and I have also cried during
both those movies I haven't seen Forrest
Gump yet Titanic is such no if I cried
during Titanic confuse its eidetic a
movie that people hate now is this a
great question I feel like that was the
backlash because of you know cute boy
leo at the time but I feel like it has
aged it's weird it's like even
detractors it's not like Avatar where
nobody seems to like it but it still has
its status I feel like Titanic is a
respected film whether people like it or
not well dude I'm glad you remember that
what Carter what movie made you cry at
22 years old stream
guys I love that there's a comment about
big fish added to Lisa Marie because
Lisa Marie is in several temper joints
Oh is she
Lisa Marie is oh I get you hi Lisa Marie
not this loose Marie though highly
red-room trainer always my god it's hot
in here
red room train drainer train play when
Luke Skywalker takes off Darth Vader's
helmet you know I'm always so into the
design of Vader when the helmet is off
that I can't get absorbed so much into
the emotional moment of it because
you're like this white face thing inside
just trying to take in with Vader like
although when I rewatched the Skywalker
saga in timeline order I did get more
emotional when I got to that part in
Return of the Jedi because I was heavily
invested in Jake Lloyd in the Phantom
Menace
hey man without a little boy you have to
be this overweight we're white albeit oh
poor child that probably ruined his life
more or two is like oh people are
thinking I'm gonna grow up in this
doughy guy guys look
you you you might think we missed your
super chats but trust me we just haven't
gotten we deserve got into you're living
in the future we're living in the past
we will get there Oh always we will get
there let's see Brendan V we did Carter
Lovejoy random Andy all right
ooh random Andy's channel random Andy
Thank You random random Andy's channel
he's back in the gas sexy profile page
Johnny Bravo the man waiting till
marriage
huh who the shape of water it was the
only highlight of the whole month when I
took my mom to get Mexico to get
treatment and it took me away for a
couple hours then I saw Coco could okay
so here's how I read your story and this
sounds like a really emotional
experience that you went on of taking
around to Mexico to get treatment and I
hope she's doing better now buddy it
sounds like the way I read it though was
you saw the shape of water and then you
had to take your mom to Mack
ago because you couldn't handle the
shape of water to get treatment it took
and it's fine now I can't enjoy shape of
water I'm gonna go watch cocoa with all
the other Mexicans in Mexico doctor this
woman wants the shape of water we need
to operate here's a cup of cocoa wait
here that coffee in the operating room
as well part of the treatment for a
shape of water syndrome
well did I mean that's the power of
cinema though when you're able to when
you're going through something really
hard and then you go to go watch a movie
that could take your mind off things a
movie in a different emotional sometimes
sometimes I'm like stressed about
something but like before filming or
whatever or the day or the week coming
and then sometimes I'll watch a movie or
a show and then having having a tear
come out like really crying out of like
a a show or movie just does bring the
sense of relief to make it easier to go
and do the do the work and go about the
week so yeah Swiss Army Man was a movie
that I cried a lot during actually and
then when that Swiss Army man it's a
great movie it's a great movie check it
out check it out it's very emotional
this is a very emotional film and it's
also very quirky and off the walls it
that's one of those movies that captured
something that few movies I've ever seen
do or you like it's the weird ineffable
difficult beauty of being alive like
that's that yeah it's a special movie I
think all right here we go here we go
John let's play some catch it oh boy at
yup guys are jumping on the train all
the people who by Jack I see you leaving
the chat series of us good call all
right
genre would what's up dude couldn't see
here buddy yo yo he said hey guys love
your vids and I can't stay long I just
wanted to suggest if you wanted
something funnier at you try the fnaf oh
my god Aneesa you're on lunch break and
you're super chatting us no work
people's wives keep us in the background
work so really sweet and needs to thank
you there's five nights at Freddy's vs.
Ghostbusters I forgot to see the
screenshot this I'm screenshot anybody I
want to
that's so bad all right thank you dude
good golly appreciate it that sounds
like a fun time yeah all right so
scourge a sausage in 1999 is saying a
rival got me bad finale with the
beautiful got me into a badass finale
with the beautiful score that's true a
lot of times scenes will not be as
emotional unless the score is there
sometimes I feel like the score of
things can kind of like be a little too
much like there's like I get it I know
how yeah you know it's got its got a
harmonized and it's got to elevate
something that's already within the
footage not just tell you an emotion
yeah because since I'm sitting in just
the the quietness of the atmosphere like
take like the one that does going to
mine is endgame with like Toni dying
like before the music crescendo kicks in
it's just quiet around there
this is debris here in the background
and fire trickling you know and I like
that the being caught in the reality
that can often be more powerful than
having like swelling music kicking in
yeah you just feel the room in the air
and then it puts you really soberly I
think feet on the ground in a way yes oh
sure like a death scene I think yes yeah
I feel like a lot of death scenes
actually benefit from the lack of music
but that's just me shutter island' ooh
there's some there's some heavy stuff
inside shutter island' marriage story
ABC marry Surya uh not beyond that first
40 minutes God such a funny movie it
sounds like yeah I can't wait because
supposedly is that that's what I've been
told is that they advertise it like it
was only going to be this drama and it's
actually pretty funny all right so what
are we at here we are at Carter again
Carter back in the chart also Snape's
memories in Deathly Hallows part-2 oh my
god he was in love with Lily
that's right Lily Potter's mother you
haven't seen it I know I can see it yeah
the storm scene Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows part-2
I haven't you're not a true Potter head
that's right that's right through Harry
Potter fan it's not enough to read all
the books did you read the whole book
read all the books and I've listened to
them multiple times on you haven't seen
the deathly hallows part I haven't seen
seven or seven part two what is wrong
with you how are you gonna be in the
inner geekdom by having read the books
and then also by having a decent
knowledge of what's been in the movies
up till that point then also I'll
probably watch at least one of those
movies tonight and then you know who
does he play in fantastic beast this guy
right here Colin Farrell he plays the
guy from the Ministry of Magic Returns
out to be well I don't want to spoil it
for everybody I don't remember what his
name is before god damn it John what
before he's Grindelwald I don't remember
what his name is he's like the [ __ ]
or guy he's like I'm gonna whisper to
you guys Percival graves that was
Percival graves I knew that I know your
movies John that character who's also in
not a book CLB Bartlett what's up Elba
Albay we just put up a shout out for you
today out late from Arkansas hmm that's
just generic southern guy never let me
go a little indie flick with Keira
Knightley Andrew Garfield and carry my
if Carey Mulligan's in the movie odds
are it's gonna be a tear drew he always
goes for the super [ __ ] heavy one
once you gonna do some slapstick comedy
you know destroy me it's so sad yeah
that dude is is that what didn't Alex
Garland lb if you catch this question
comment did did Alex garland write that
movie because I remember distinctly when
it came out it's one that's been almost
never let me go
yeah isn't that's a [ __ ] the the the
a 24-hour one no night I'm thinking I
like the lake or whatever oh no no no is
it yeah on thing now yeah this is uh
this is about it's a vaguely sci-fi
drama I think about like clones or
something I'm not sure no whoa are
people ruining hey if there's any
spoilers in here for my show
supernatural you better not say it don't
you be ruining supernatural I will kill
all I won't
but oh my god this is me we can't read
the live stream now I don't know we need
a moderator we do we do you see it no I
think I saw it that's too bad
apparently DiCaprio does not get on to
the door who the roads
I've been holding I've been waiting to
finish the movie just so I could see
that happen man so I could see him live
let's see here yes rest in peace someone
said joking on top of the car when he's
doing that got him teary-eyed I don't
know why I'll get some material do you
want to start your own yeah violent
revolution or the reason was that movie
Curtis is a man or are you hoping to
start a Joker esque movement yourself
because I can definitely see it be
moving in that scenario alright that's
great because he played some catch up
hopefully we do not get oh I think I got
supernatural spoil for me someone put it
in the comments that's the risk you run
here yeah risk you run here surprised
it's taken this many streams I guess to
get this let's see here
James Mille boys don't cry
that's a hard I mean that's a hard movie
good call though thank you James Melia
for that contribution that's a really
great call to curtain Kusama direct that
tour was that only girl fight Karyn
Kusama she didn't direct boys don't cry
okay I'm so how are you gonna ever do
well in the inner geek though that's
right boys don't cry Million Dollar Baby
Hilary Swank wheels in that one don't
roll Clint Eastwood a geared toward zinc
you know my homeboy geared towards ink
on Instagram you and I still got a
chamfer amazing shoes you haven't
message him back
I haven't FaceTime what the hell
different it's up to you DJ hello for me
and my girlfriend Amanda Amanda wants to
know Greg will you have a threesome with
me and my girlfriend the answer is no my
girlfriend won't let me partake but she
can partake with you guys that will
stand mid 90s made me cry the mid-90s
were
ruff that's very cynical the the Rodney
Dangerfield story yes Rodney Dangerfield
really suffered
Homer Simpson killed his wife it was a
really tough time in the midnight was
I'm a 90s kid you know so if we want to
ask him about 90's history I really know
my [ __ ] Nintendo yeah dude
[ __ ] weird science it was emotional
and it had some ten scenes mid-90s I
haven't seen that yet I haven't - I
would like to it looked interesting at
least I'm excited I'm interested we'll
get our second one at the hour and a
half you know how what Jonah Hill's
directing chops but that's good I'm glad
to know it's emotional yeah guys sorry
we're lagging you gotta understand man I
had Time Warner come in here let me say
this to people in person I had time we
have spectrum we have the highest grade
Internet you could afford and right now
spectrum just having so many problems
and yeah we are often having lagging
issues right now so we're doing the best
we possibly can
Lag EULA and I'm sorry about that but
you know eventually it all makes sense
sorry about the sinking I just love that
just a kessler is just shouting okay
okay bye Red Room trainer who funny
people yeah that gets to me for sure
dude especially that original cut we saw
at that test yeah ever forget oh my god
if we're like 40 minutes behind
I'm sorry geared towards Inc alright
let's see here what do we got we got
Colin Farrell and oh my god beautiful
bliss real men do cry do cry you heard
it here first going off of your comment
beautiful bliss what I'll say that that
is I used to say I used to realize calm
right here real man do cry I used to say
that to be a man that means you got to
face your fears and the thing is a lot
of men are scared to feel their tears so
if to be a real man you gotta be willing
to feel yeah yeah scary - yeah you
should you should challenge that feeling
F sphere and vote for Trump and Biden
this fall vote for them both make it
happen
PJ a new patron of ours in the last
livestream what's up dude what's up guys
pant and mcjones checking in yeah buddy
way to embrace that I hope that's what
you put on your applications for your
new job the pursuit of happiness is one
for me avengers endgame gets me overtime
when Thanos loses just kidding and no
you're not we all know the actual scene
that gets me comment John yes and the
rat turns on the time machine whatever
it takes you feel John 9 thank you
Queen edgy Saint answer my DMS are
either what did someone send me a dick
pic recently really yeah it was it a
good dick or was it not a good dick I
thought it was my dick that's strange in
Ohio how did you get this where the
answer to your DMS yes answer turned me
off
yeah the Green Mile I was like the first
movie I brought up gladiator haven't
seen honey boy yeah now I gotta check on
me boy boy and peanut butter Falcon both
I need to see from last year Shia is
coming back dude call me by your name
did make me cry
you guys should watch my review for call
me by your name
you'll see it you'll see that like as
I'm doing my review I start to cry
that's all I'm gonna say
cries well your name made me cry
absolutely call me by your peach all
right we are everywhere see what's
misleading about these super chats that
we think we're on track
you got this scroll bar here but then
when you adjust it again then you adjust
it on there and then you're like oh my
god we're way behind guys are way behind
what happened to my mouth what happened
to mom Mel what happened to my mouth of
course I read all the comments Erik
horsemen my homie dude I wish they had
the time of when the comments come in
here a hare hoar 79 p.m. faint so wish
granted and this these are moments of
Tears there were 30 with two minutes but
33 minutes behind all right all right
we'll get there friggin late Erik thank
you for dude that's such a big super
chat buddy Thank You Man freakin late
again
any movie where an animal is abused hurt
and or dies that damn movie up the
weeper of all weepers I mean the total
ugly cry terms of endearment
oh yeah no there there's two people in
my life that I know that cannot handle
animal death or animal abuse scenes
whatsoever
Olivia and a guy who you've seen on this
channel for sure if you've been watching
channel long enough our great friend one
of my best friends Andrew Gordon he can
he like he hasn't seen any a game of
Thrones because of the amount of animal
deaths are in it he and he you know he
doesn't like spoilers either like Olivia
will something spoiled for her just so
she can make sure to skip an animal at
that scene and sometimes I do that too
it's like we want to go at your pet
cemetery for an operative question Erik
horseman or if you watch Pet Sematary
I was like [ __ ] she agreed to go I
talked to the Wendy Lee at Collider and
it says whole long conversation with her
and I texted Jon Roca and pairing them
off let's try and make sure like guys
what animal deaths are there so I could
keep a [ __ ] lookout for that [ __ ] and
I hate when people give me answers of
like yeah this thing happens but don't
worry if there's gonna be some sweet
revenge in the end that's like telling
me yeah the dog dies in John wick but
wishing to [ __ ] them up I'm still like I
didn't know where the dogs gonna die
that's the part that's good fruit of
glad the movie will do that but I'm
gonna get a major trouble if I do not
successfully appoint this month not
asking for me okay yeah about my taste I
feel you there at another movie that
made me ugly cry a World Trade Center oh
oh I bet yeah yeah I'm one really made
me cry ya know
anything that pulls like a real entity
onto the screen
absolutely is a tricky one let's see if
we can end this livestream on time by
6:15 oh man that's that's gonna be every
super chick gets one word answers today
yes I to cry good choice let's see here
oh man endure here we are alive PS I
love you who's the guy on the right
amber Jones I know that name I swear my
weekends are now revolved around
watching these live streams and drinking
alone you're not drinking alone tonight
amber right here with us we got orange
juice in there orange juice and a little
bit of fun Samara misses face his face
thank you buddy bye tales of Iroh leaves
from the vine falling so slowly like
fragile oh my god this is a poetic super
chat tales of Iroh leaves from the vine
falling so slowly John let's state in
harmony like fragile tiny shells
drifting in the foam little soldier boy
come marching home brave soldier boy
come marching home oh it is a song I see
the musical notes now do you know that
song I don't actually at least not by
the lyrics alone and our havin to Darvin
izing them but I would like to look it
up
maybe I'll cry is there a song you cry
oh goodness broad you probably I would
have to put some thought on that but I
I'm trying to think there there is a
song that there's a song I really really
love by a band called spoon
good night Laura that's kind of like a
lullaby and it's very sweet and it's
very dear and it's not made specifically
for sad scenarios although it does uh
come back to me in a lot of occasions
and one of those occasions is when
somebody you know leaves the mortal
plane and so I've cried to that song a
fair few times I don't know if it's if
that context didn't exist if it would be
the same but it is a very emotionally
affecting song you know there's a song
that made me cry by who's the girl
Regina Spektor mm-hmm
Regina Spektor has a song called that
time and in the third verse that's like
the the music's always building and then
by the time you get to this part in the
bursts like a lot of the instruments
drop out and her voice goes really quiet
and soft because it's a story of like
reflecting with a past lover I like to
remember that time when this happened
that time it's like a lot of lyrics and
then when the music's really loud and
then it suddenly slows down and she goes
do you remember that time that you would
eat and then it's like really heavy and
he almost never almost died on overdose
situation and that was like oh I thought
this was just about missing your ex she
paints such a great picture with her
boyfriend having this like great ass
background story for sure yeah like quoi
there's a Queens of the Stone Age song
called like clockwork that is incredibly
heart-wrenching and that song I know has
made me cry
I appear missing I think is another one
do you guys have songs that I made you
cry Dragonheart yeah sure hard
oh yeah no with the tracks on Connor the
dragon and your boy few lists as the
sniffily like prince gaya and yes your
answer someone's question here yeah I I
know I look like javac away for a reason
what I am part of the stem cell research
program 2000s and then I was born
gotta love stem cells yeah clb chiming
in about the regina spektor song - let's
tune together a jam jam here in our live
stream yeah dude the Imogen Heap song
from the dear
what you say Peter grin doll Dumbo
thank you Peter that's a big what your
your profile pic is gone he's the guy
from Norway with the awesome profile
what the [ __ ] Peter with the with the
intense eyes why'd you take away your
profile pic we loved it
pitar Peter Peter I'm letting you know
that if we make a crack like that that's
because we actually love it you good let
me never mean anything in a mean way
please bring your profile pic is great
we look [ __ ] you're good dude don't do
that
Dumbo the moment Dumbo's mom tries to
confront him while she's locked up in a
cell that's hard yeah oh yeah when
Dumbo's mom comes in and she's like were
you smoking reefer at the circus Dumbo
Dumbo I'm gonna trunk slap you so I get
over get over here and then Dumbo's oh
my god has a really heartbreaking scene
that's a big lesson for a lot of kids I
mean I'm a big Disney fan but I think
Disney took it a little too far and I'm
glad they kept it out of the remake and
added in all that stuff with those kids
that they care about
hey-oh box happy to see you in the chat
oh my goodness gracious jarhead I
remember that movie I don't think I
cried but it's definitely a a heavy
movie or jarhead yeah I cried when he's
like trying to masturbate in the
bathroom can't [ __ ] do it I know yeah
how many times I've been in that
scenario you're not a Disney fan Olivia
you're a liar yeah liar liar plants for
you guys wanna see a tease for something
that we're gonna put out look at that oh
do you guys oh do you guys did you guys
see it you're gonna make them do you
guys see oh do you guys see look at a
collaboration tomorrow that's Leigh
Whannell and Jason Blum and they're
joining the channel they're joining this
rejects because they got nothing else
better to do guys we don't know how to
make movies anymore you have to do it
Leigh Whannell director of Invisible Man
Jason Blum had a Blum ask I do an
interview with them video should be you
have either tomorrow
Monday anyway have a work day Nancy you
know known as the lies dream today I are
the female presence the few the 15%
demographic of the audience the real
rejects are working today yeah why is
the world getting woke or women are
working hey but Nancy is doing a great
service to us and various creators by
trying to support creators i watch a lot
more so yo saturday smiley face Nancy
you are the shiznit
thank you for chiming in today Nancy
it's really sweet of you thank you thank
you for your love and for your support
like I guess it sounds trite when people
say that a lot but seriously Thank You
Nancy
thank you hey Erick are you getting so
mad in the chat right now what do you
have seriously
alright so scourge a 1999 my girl he
can't see without his glasses well what
does that mean and it gotta be it's
gotta be the film my girl and the moment
of you can't see without his glasses are
you telling the truth that's a literal
guess I think there is a film called my
girl I haven't seen this moment but I'm
guessing that it's a moment from my girl
and nature I have just told you guessing
based on what I think is true I'm not
doing a bit if that's what you want to
know but actually this this Kindles
something within me so scare ya
because are oddly enough people losing
their glasses or having glasses broken
makes me very sentimental in in movies
in general in fact sentimental for the
recliner a glasses I know I know but
there's something about that where like
a character loses their glasses and they
can't see and like they're helpless and
that makes me so sad in in such a
weirdly specific way and yeah I didn't
have glasses growing up so I don't know
why but every time I've seen that in a
movie or show it makes me feel a very
specific kind of sadness and in the
mummy 1999 oh the do when he's oh yeah
when he's in the underground yeah
glasses can't see and I don't know if I
if I all the way cried but if I didn't I
got close because I felt so bad for that
guy I was like you know you're you're
bound to this invention that if you lose
it you know it says I could do a whole
livestream of all the moments and
friends that made me cry and by the way
everyone in the chat who's seen my girl
is uh is agreeing with you yeah yeah
thanks so thanks for the backup people
tell him I'm uh I could do a whole
livestream about all the scenes and
friends that made me cry do it right now
like when when Ross at the last episode
is like did she get off the plane and
then you hear Rachel in the background
to say I got off the plane oh my god
they were meant to be and she was not
meant to pursue her career and friends
don't broaden your horizons that way
that door I guess I could see that I I
don't know I mean I think the only MCU
movie that really made me cook actually
know Erik kill mongers death scene in
Black Panther did make me cry for sure
yeah yeah that's emotional let's see
here
Joe Norwood back in the live stream chat
the bucket list with Jack Nicholson and
Morgan Freeman always breaks my heart
appreciate your super chat buddy and
yeah that is a very like that was a
movie that critics didn't really love
but it's a definite crowd-pleaser and a
tearjerker of a movie so I gotta give
that to you man yes I'm gonna have to
watch it and Eric horseman back again
you don't have to keep superjet anybody
appreciate all you've contributed so far
though anyone mentioned a marriage story
will f you up yes we we have mention
actually yeah you know the the scene in
a merits Tory when Adam driver is
reading a letter towards the end of the
movie that scene really made me
emotional for him not the big scene that
kept going around Twitter where he's
like [ __ ] losing it yeah the scene
weather that everybody captured if
you've ever been to an acting class
you've seen this scene oh is that there
were made
one of without him Trevor bad he's
[ __ ] great in that scene well there
yeah I mean from what I understand the
acting is great there but yeah that's
what I will look to that yelling scene
that was no it's gonna come eventually
in that movie they like know for sure
but I I that was I saw that sentiment
echoed a lot of like yep ever every
acting class ever
oh actually you know darkside masters
bringing up in the chat with yondu's
death and guardians of the galaxy vol 2
that did get that was act that was my
favorite part of that movie yeah all the
yondu stuff yes let's see don't be sorry
for being late just be happy for being
here it's emotional for a lot of people
I'm glad to see a kung fu hustle
name-check I'm gonna have to go back and
watch that one again foo hustle made
someone cry that surprised the mute girl
scene I'm trying to drive to memory I
know I've seen the movie but still
hour-and-a-half in and we're still on
the same topic this is never the best
about ourselves never happened before
crazy I don't never happen again at
beautiful anyways super chats are about
it that's crazy I'm just proud proud of
this livestream today we did it guys
beautiful bliss beautiful lists you
bring me beautiful you bring me okay you
know that's a beautiful big bliss boobs
Hacksaw ridge is based on a real story
it's pretty damn close to real life you
know I never looked up how thank you for
your super chat by the way I've never
looked up how accurate of accurate of a
movie that was but do you really do all
I've I heard Mel Gibson hmm the man
right here
I heard him why say that there was so
much they didn't put in it that is true
but they he didn't think that in the
movie and the time allotted that people
would believe that any of that actually
happened that he actually pulled off in
that in real life so the movie is like
truth light yeah like it's the true
stuff but with more of
taken out just because people wouldn't
believe how true it is I mean not only
did he save people in a world war 2
without using any guns
any weapons he saved a bunch of lives on
the battlefield he also resurrected
people from the dead and because there
was a lack of breathing room in hacksaw
bridge they had enough time to let
people really believe the truth it's too
much mumbo-jumbo asmin Doss saved a
bunch of brought people back from the
dead but he did it look I read a book
read a book you'll find it he's a
descendant of Jesus and Joe Biden if you
didn't watch hacks I read you're not
black and you're not by oh yeah dude oh
why so embarrass and I feel like every
time a politician goes on like The
Breakfast Club or something like that
it's always like I want to see one of
those go well maybe Obama did one but I
just flashback to Hillary Clinton in the
hot sauce thing I'm like stop pandering
there's this comedian Hannah Bart not
Barbara Hannah
something and I get ya the Australian
comedian she has a Netflix special that
was like oh a strange experience because
it's such a vulnerable stand-up comedy
special that was having me go from like
skyrocketing laughter to just a mess of
tears up and down up and down that is a
very unique stand-up special and that
was yeah that was an incredible one
Hannah Gatsby did that to me and also um
Chris Gethard HBO special oh did you
watch that the Hannah gas that we saw is
special oh yeah and that yeah
in fact on your and on your
recommendation at the old apartment I
put it on and really yeah and you quite
quite moving quite funny both all the
above and yeah I just had a very similar
experience I wish I remembered the
title of it but yeah if you go on HBO
Chris Gethard does like a one-man
one-man show / stand-up set that is
equally vulnerable but also hilarya
maybe don't double feature them
otherwise you'll be a weepy mess well
dude guys if you haven't hit the like
button and make sure to hit the like
button we're going an hour 37 minutes
we're doing okay The Dark Knight Rises
no I never cried at that I thought I
would yeah I didn't cry I I had a great
time a beautiful boy beautiful mind a
beautiful mind a beautiful boy beautiful
mind yeah beautiful with Javier Bardem
Dylan winter what's up buddy you're
overdoing it and it's super effective
what is that oh okay so yeah Dylan
winder someone in okay amber is talking
with someone about six cents unbreakable
that made me cry at the the one of the
closer to last scenes when Bruce Willis
is across from his son and then he opens
up the newspaper sees the hooded figure
and he sees the hooded figure and he
thinks it's his dad who's Bruce Willis
and and then he loaded the the special
tree Clark is the kids named Esther
shoot car looks up at his dad across the
table but the moms in the corner she
doesn't know about what he really does
and he just goes like this and then they
both start to cry oh my god yeah they
share this kid ninh he knows the truth
and then he or the son always believed
in him and oh my god that is that is a
very [ __ ] emotional scene yeah that's
a great one yeah Cowell good Simon
Cahokia M night Shyamalan
hey master tearjerker I'm night Creed
too with the baby's loss of hearings
yeah yeah Creed tunes emotional Michael
B Jordans good at picking emotional
projects all right where we at here
twins in Kindergarten Cop give me
nostalgic tears thanks sauce June 1999 I
would say so
gonna caught more for me than twins not
so tough without your car Kindergarten
Cop really got to me who's your daddy
and what boys have a girls have a vagina
I cried because I didn't know that when
I first saw
all right we're temporarily caught up
with the super chats in this stream
format here Oh od orlando haiti a theory
of everything i am sam milk Mystic River
dead man walking Fast Times at Ridgemont
High the interpreter the report dark
waters spotlight trust naming Sean Penn
movies oh they're all Sean Penn movie
yeah yeah this guy doesn't know movies I
don't know how I ever did well on the
ship around that one year that's easy
jeez get those questions I haven't seen
a theory of everything but I am Sam and
milk yeah those are definitely emotional
movies man theory of everything I will
vouch for as being an emotional
experience saw that the theater and
Charlie Cox is in it yeah uh-huh
the guy who's not Stephen Hawking but
winds up being like I don't want to tell
you in case that spoils the movie of
these people's real lives
he basically it's a weird position for
him as a character though because he's
basically got a you know be with Stephen
Hawking's wife is there any movies that
you've seen both Thank You Kate Orlando
and now you your mom and that your
daughter I hope you guys are having a
great weekend or you the little girl and
that's your mom and this is a you're on
as shouldn't have YouTube ask your mom
for her credit card information so you
can increase your super chat then then
you'd be good Gus have you had any
emotional like tier experience like
teary-eyed experiences or crying
experiences with your folks around that
you that you were like cuz when I cry
around my family with a movie I really
don't want them you want I really have
no waitress even though I just feel like
they're gonna like like that make fun of
me but insult me
they're gonna be looking at you they're
gonna judge me or some [ __ ] you go I've
had some like real heart-to-heart
moments of my family and we've cried
about stuff to this day if I'm crying in
a movie and they're next to me
they're the last people I'll let I'll
let everyone next to me who I don't know
let all and I'll let them see me cry but
I don't want my family you get like
braised in about like I'll cry in front
of strangers I don't care yeah but yeah
if it's my my closest living relative I
I get that way a bit I mean yeah if I'm
with my family there is a bit more of
like okay I'm gonna maintain my my
composure but if it's a film that's just
knocked us all over you know I'm trying
to think of a good example though so
what is there a movie that as a family
you've collectively cried together for
goodness golly um there has to be one I
feel like there is one but I would need
a moment just to Rack my my brain for me
it was real Trade Centre it's all I
could think of yeah that I could I was
like we're all crying together on this
one I feel it you know I feel it mm-hmm
but that's the only one I could really
think of yeah I'm trying to think of
ease that have like a certain whimsy or
something or that we all like if we're
all getting out there it's typically not
on the heavier dramatic end of the
spectrum I don't want to cop out I know
I cried with my family during again 1917
but there's probably a better I know I
can feel it there's a better example
than that and then I can't put my finger
on it yet I feel like our generation you
know like how all of our friends are
having kids that I feel like our
generation with their kids they're gonna
be willing to cry with that I would hope
so as I think that like it's still at
our age and our parents like your
parents a little bit more on the
sensitive side than the most a lot of
other parents were like I don't feel
like your family would like make fun of
you or judge you for crying my family
definitely yeah but but I think like our
generation and with their kids there
that are gonna be like family you know
with tears and stuff I think it's gonna
be more acceptable more willing
you can see that for sure I could
definitely see the future generations
yeah as we as men learned that it's okay
to cry where we are here Anissa Anissa
should be working she should be working
where is it easily we'll play that game
right here an ISA is not working at the
emergency room she's supposed to be
working at the emergency room and what
she's doing is slacking off starting
some coke and putting it up with some
hardcore Texans who accidentally shot
themselves in the knee today and she's
trying you to try to just get away from
work yeah I don't blame you play that
hooky leave them to you can take care of
themselves yeah man you're in Texas and
then well I need to fix this I need to
we need Mel and Collin Farrel the two
greatest men of all time to be showing
Mel sad porn star Colin Farrell DCF Ron
Ron is the currency Romania and not my
name we totally shout out the currency
very sorry about that dcs and and
actually i could tease this some ryan in
the okay hold on psych and the live 8
seam from Bohemian Rhapsody was movie
magic for me and sparked my newfound
love for Queen you know what else is
great movie magic
what's great magic of the Live Aid
performance watching the YouTube video
of the actual performance uncut real
experience damn good I mean I don't love
that movie but I will I cannot begrudge
anybody that that rush of emotion for
the Live Aid scene because I feel like
if I was fully pulled into that movie I
might have gotten there to this just
[ __ ] man so yeah yeah it's okay DCF even
if we're not here with you I just
spiritually with just with Bohemian
Rhapsody I'm just like one of those
people that like that's something I get
with Ally
it seen I get why people are moved I
just have this complete different
perspective on that scene whatever I
won't ruin it for you I'm glad you love
Ohanian Rhapsody and rami malek is
incredible in the role so I'm glad you
loved it and Bryan Singer's a great
director Sean what Harvey Weinstein
deserves Wow satire
Wow joy will I to take it all back it's
not satire he's made that comment to me
in private many times I know Peter
Grindle has got his profile pic yes
thank you buddy
yes I'm sorry his name is Peter Green
doll nope I do cry yeah make that
mistake from the last yes peter krandall
nope thanks for being your dude admit it
guys you cry when you see my face I
don't cry I go I become like a little
boy on the inside because I'm so scared
of the intimidation you reject my way
well yeah you can cry out of a you know
tears of fear but thank you dude I
appreciate that
I appreciate that big time oh yeah I
definitely cry when I see your face for
a lot of different reasons it's very
conflicting oh yeah Oh 100% Jackson
Perez great call the old message scenes
from interstellar when he gets back from
the water planet crushed me every time
the goddamn the scene that became like a
million when he's when Matt McConaughey
is crying and people did these like
hilarious videos of him reading
McConaughey reacting to the Star Wars
trailer he's crying like like that seems
so good he's so [ __ ] good in that
scene and yeah that like like I can't
what it's a meme in the theaters I was
crying like a little baby I think I was
a very emotional so yeah yeah yeah and I
mean you know I feel like Matthew
McConaughey has a meme quality just his
persona but but that scene really breaks
through it and yeah like it's impossible
not to react emotionally amber in the
chat saying she cried in front of her
dad for in Bruges what I'm seen in
Bruges it make someone cry when the
little person gets shot oh yeah yeah so
little oh didn't see him is that what he
said
or great finds is like oh I see that's a
great movie I'm not exactly sure where
you would cry tell us where you cried
where did you cry was it towards like
the very very end when you know the
ambiguous thing is taking over ah what
[ __ ] and this is not in the chat
anymore I'll kill her I'll kill you I'm
an ambassador right away what are you
doing all right well let me see where we
are the chat oh man we are we're almost
okay oh we're slightly caught up the
gene Jeter what's up buddy quarantine
and chill part three check outs channel
the ending of you've got mail gave me
tears of joy or on the inside I wanted
it to be you Meg Ryan's character ah
yeah see it like a rom-com like that
will definitely make me cry that's like
love acts of love are always way more
powerful to me in terms of being moved
to tears than any other type of thing
that might provoke tears
yeah the acts of love like that so
rom-coms often do make me cry yeah
that's a good you don't cry rom-coms
i have you're always lying why are
people dating just [ __ ] each other move
on yeah we kill every romantic comedy
what is there they go [ __ ] what he's
here to bother with all this dialogue
and connection just [ __ ] alright guys
don't realize he's a perv I mostly just
watched pornography films yes James we
did read your super chat buddy that's
why you can't leave you got to be very
patient you got to be so patient wait
around you submit a super chat you gotta
give us at least an hour to get there
we'll get there
yeah it'll be on a massive delay but
worth thorough if not rise we try to hop
around between non super chats and super
chats it's just us chiming and about our
own thing but yeah gene Jeter I'll meet
you there buddy
and also the original one that it's
based off of what is the original one my
girlfriend's in a murder maybe she
showed me that one oh is it like a
classic film yeah it's a classic film
yeah
I forget maybe she'll show comment in
the chat and call you an idiot or
something let's see here oh wait a
minute I think I think we have I think
we're caught up on the regular chai oh
yeah we are
oh look out bernie's back Jorge Lopez
caught Thank You Bernie Alvarado George
Lopez comedy show why you crying made me
cry laughter ha ha ha I remember vividly
when that dropped I've never seen this
special but I remember it being
advertised constantly it's funny because
George Lopez show is like a funny family
show and then you listen to a stand-up
you're like oh really you ever heard any
George Lopez I swear isn't [ __ ] now I'm
interested ok but I Bob Saget had the
same thing with me like Bob Saget on
pole house and then suddenly you hear
stands like this guys go oh yeah Bob
Saget yeah like like Ray Romano stand up
from Everybody Loves Raymond is is like
it's like an edgy version of Ray Romano
from everybody who's right but dude
what's a movie that made me cry of
laughter there's definitely there's
something I've reacted to on this
channel that it was like one of those
supernatural conventions where I was
crying of laughter for sure there's
definitely a movie yes my dad cried of
laughter during was it the influence bit
with the talk about cast eels influence
but there was definitely by Ashley get
some sleep
but there was uh there's definitely a
movie uh I think a recent saw the movie
good boys and I'm gonna turn a
Middleditch in Schwartz a Netflix
special there was a moment that made me
cry of laughter for sure watch that [ __ ]
each one a cry of laughs so thanks for
reminding me of that Bernie Alvarado
means a lot
means the world actually saw a scene in
The Sopranos recently where this over a
woman of a wife of a mob guy is
struggling with losing weight and then
their company's the husband's coming
down very hard and she gets like very
emotional and vulnerable how hard it is
for her to lose weight
and man that Ike you her screen time on
the shows like 30 minutes of screen time
in total so far over the course of many
episodes and that [ __ ] really got to me
as I could relate with that yeah I can
like losing weight is a very as it very
hard that's I mean I yeah that's like a
very human relatable thing I would love
to see that scene I love moments like
that especially when like an actor who's
like been around or whatever popping up
here and there like actually gets a
moment to really make an impression with
the scene or yeah that's always really
gratifying I mean if you guys want to
see John shirtless you should check out
our Star Wars fan film reaction the
Kenobi Star Wars FAL for reaction yeah
see John shirtless check out that hot
bod the put the picture you post on page
brown is perhaps one of my least
favorite pictures of myself ever why
post the one right next to me of you
your body looks a lot better than my
right now what are you talking about I'm
a little doughy right now what no but it
doesn't show it all dude like I'm a
little bloated it shows in my face look
I look heavier than you naturally with
your shirt on usually we put those on
when the camera starts to roll but the
rest of the time and then gpk the
product people he took the photo himself
it was like you're going above and
beyond hey I'm glad then then then thank
you for prom sorry I didn't realize it
was gonna make you feel self-conscious
Erla snake itself it's a way here and
there wait wait you guys aren't enjoying
there's people in the chat who
apparently don't like that photo what
the hell Wow
thanks guys after all this the photo now
I find out I was right all along - hey
it looks better in the in the video
where you can't see the bottom of my
stomach
so I was doing the full-body shadows
like lining it with the wall I'm now in
a perfect crime it's reality it's good
I'm sorry all right
what made John cry was the photo I
posted on patreon of a shirt this is a
good reminder to keep it those one
minute planks every day I'm sorry and
he's uh no Nisa your major super chatter
so sweet she said I'm on lunch just
wanted to stop by and say hi I wish I
could be here the entire time you both
know just out here helping save lives oh
wait actually ready yourself pursuit of
happiness all the right places in cocoa
because it reminds me of my great
grandmother who are close to not sweet
on this I miss you you know who makes me
cry you made me cry because of how much
you have been so supportive to us and go
so far beyond I love you and he said
John tell her Aneesa nobody goes is
above and beyond as you do for this
channel
alright showed the naked photo shirtless
photo of us primarily so she could see
you would wear shirts like my shirt off
now for Aneesa Bryan I'll take my shirt
off she's not even here do it John
unless somebody else how discouraging
would it be if you took your shirt off
and everyone that everyone left alone
and then all those likes that went away
never show you the new surprise and now
I really don't want to test this theory
out no you're fine I'd really be funny
if it actually happening I feel really
bad I would be amused initially and then
I would go home and feel very bad yeah
alright so yeah oh yeah let's let's
catch up your attack and release Thank
You Aneesa beautiful bliss thanks again
buddy
Tony Stark Tony Stark death
that's your Marvel Game of Thrones cover
band let's cover all the theme music
you're such a slag John I don't know
what that means
who a slag that's not an endearing term
at least over season when you're
slagging somebody off it's not a good
thing so thanks Gisele Sinclair all
right so um love lamb z-waves 2019 was
incredibly depressing I see that I heard
well thanks for your super chat dude
who's this badass is that you look a
badass [ __ ] right here man yeah
thanks what's that name mean love lamzy
I got nothing for EM sorry
this guy's Lando waves wait I think I've
seen a little bit of that that's like a
John answer I've seen bits and pieces
yeah which is enough to qualify well it
depends I mean usually when I say I've
seen bits and pieces I just try to speak
to the impression that they gave me slag
is like [ __ ] in the UK yeah but you like
that [ __ ] jaw okay I guess I am a slag
and at least in terms o total yes and
you because it's not as mean as I
thought it was Ethan Holgate go back to
the beginning of this live stream I
mentioned the patriot of what you're
talking about times thank you love lamzy
Kolby Franklin what you got in store for
us thank you for your super chat dude a
movie that made me cry was the real
rejects movie such a motion in that
movie Greg and John those are such
amazing actors that brought me to tears
oh thanks Colby Franklin you're one of
the few people that saw if you guys
haven't seen the real rejects movie what
basically happens in it is Greg and John
they go on the movie trivia Schmoe down
match in case you guys don't know what
that is it's exactly what it sounds like
it's a movie trivia competition show and
they and they end up going on the show
as a team they end up losing but then
Greg he gets caught up in a time loop
where he's able to keep going on the
same match every single day
because everyone's like people should
stop Greg and John should be teamed up
anymore and then Greg gets so much power
and authority from being from getting a
perfect round one not letting John
answer belittling him
their friendship ends apart that's the
all's lost moment dark night of the soul
Greg thinks he could be on his own and
then he realizes they're better as a
team than the finale and then they lose
there you go that's the real rejects
movie for you very very time loop it was
a grueling shoot based on true events
there are mics not on are you [ __ ]
with us what I they're [ __ ] with us
yeah they're [ __ ] with us right how
did I grow a juice box you got my
attention
I see your name there I got my hair so
long by not cutting it for years on end
alright ok cue box I hear you all right
let's go here sub the director how you
doing
all right Eric horsemen back at 13 and
call me by your name Catherine Hardwicke
and Luca Guadagnino I love movies about
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
eating the Apple of knowledge Oh God h13
and calling by your name absolutely [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ] sad movies
wrong yeah oh my god yeah I thought we
were caught up yeah that's always it's
always the word yeah all right lb Thank
You lb thank you dear yes Alex Carlin
adapted the screenplay from a book what
what book is she talking about call me
by your name
Kazu made concubine
which isn't under sir what was the what
was the movie never let me go
Andrew Garfield and thanks for
clarifying that
now it's garlic - hello Ryder hell of a
ride actually I actually listen to this
video today it's like a 12-minute video
that is called structuring a screenplay
advice from working screenwriters and
Alex Garland has a tip in there that is
the most simplistic and easiest to
duplicate version of how to duplicate
not being out of screenplay so if you
guys are interested in screenwriting
just go look that up and you should find
a girl have some great advice in there
yeah all scripts end on page 90 so once
you're there you don't you got to know
everything about your characters in the
first 10 pages done Landon Smith what a
great name is an action hero me Landon
Smith sad a supernatural moment so far
for you oh god what was it
have cried and supernatural I think it
was when Dean was talking about his
experience in Hell and who he ended up
becoming and like having a murder a
bunch of souls if you guys have only
started supernatural I'm being a dick
because I'm trying to avoid supernatural
but yeah I mean that's like a season for
spoilers so worried for you yeah
somewhere there but yeah that probably
the one for me that's the most sad
supernatural moment at the moment what
comes to mind is just I'm not gonna get
too specific but at the tail end of
season 4 there's a certain realization
that comes over Sam that is very
heartbreaking oh yeah Gabriel says the
part in Supernatural when the purple guy
snaps half of all life got me in tears
he's doing Ivan ooze revenant empowering
which is Robert Englund Brenda thank you
for that Landon Smith random Andy's
channel back at it again hey Nancy I see
your dear uh she is mom Randy and we
asked about random and channel after
going to the hospital
she is better just look up love movies
both oh wait that's right I'm so sorry
he didn't mention that his mom passed
last time yeah last last time he was
you're like no it was like a stream or
two streams ago yeah that's right I've
had that happen before matter of fact
I'm gonna tell you an awkward story to
make up for my awkwardness of forgetting
about your mom passing we had a friend
in school John and I whose dad passed
away this was like in junior high when
this happened okay this is like 20 years
ago or something and then my dad was at
some event with me and then he was I was
like hanging out with the girl in the
class and and I was like talking with
her we were just having fun just like
you know chit-chatting whatever and then
my dad comes up and it's like oh hey how
are you person's name who I won't
mention for privacy and then and then
he's like oh so he's like oh like her
dad just passed like a week ago talking
about you know it'll all fit in when I
hear the end so so then then my dad says
it's like oh so is your dad in there
like in the in the room where the
parents are and that just goes no and
then I had to be like remember this is
like a few days ago ah I think it's like
oh that's right he was a great person oh
well you know just saying hey we got
life wells in here saying Ryan you're my
favorite youtuber
you're welcome Ryan right always
happened to Erik Hersman not a movie but
almost every episode of the haunting of
Hill House thanks Flannigan oh yeah Erik
horseman was like one of the main people
that got me to watch oh honey he'll he
got you to watch honey Hill House for
patreon
um yeah what there's there's something
in there that really got me emotional
Mike Flanagan just makes me emotional
[ __ ] there was definitely something in
there that got me very emotional I I
mean there yeah there are a lot of
moments I can imagine but what I mean
when they finally reveal what's up with
the bent neck lady and and Nell and that
that whole thing like that I really sent
me four I was really really impacted by
that episode in particular but like I
feel like there's got to be like a
moment with Luke or something because
especially when he's off and he's at
rehab and he's with that other woman
like I feel like there's probably
something with him that that may have
moved me that way I guess you man it's
hard up stuff I mean they tried to make
me go to rehab but I said tomorrow I'll
get some information first and then make
my own decision hey Justin Hetal in the
chat has a great question
are there any things that make you cry
because you know they are done like oh
they're done now I'm sad like this live
stream may be less now than before I
almost feel it's like oh wow they
actually committed to ending good for
you guys I still don't buy it though
Jackson Perez oh here we go another MCU
contribution or something that got am an
emotional thank you buddy
the scene from Winter Soldier when cap
is getting beat up by Bucky and says
then finish it because I'm with you till
the end of the line oh yeah that's a
great call Jackson and that's a
fantastic call Jackson time yeah good
call on that dear those kinds of moments
too were like somebody's is like
fighting with like when someone's like
fighting with a character or person they
like really are connected to or care
about and especially when one character
refuses to fight right like those
moments come on fight back you know the
person who's not fighting you're just
like that's good call Joe thank you
thank you chase Gardner The Hunger Games
Thank You chase The Hunger Games movie
series made me cry all of them every the
third one or the third one Croy but if
it made you cry to each their own tears
are subjective it made me cry in the
first one when our friend Ashton died
off-screen yeah yeah that's a real
bummer it was something at spider-man 2
that made me cry I can't remember what
exactly like not on the train you don't
know what like a moment of joy a movie
moment is when MJ is about to get
crushed by
wherever Doc Ock is and that like
[ __ ] underground spire is building
the spear thing and like she suspects
that Peter is spider-man mm-hmm but then
when he shows up tell it's so heavy but
he's also trying to have a sweet moment
yeah like that that scene the second
she's like accepting of it that really
made me and actually it's corny as this
might be my equivalent to whatever you
love about that Return of the King scene
when all the hobbits are coming and it
looks like heaven when MJ is running
leaves her wedding yeah to go be with
pic Peter yeah then it has like super
corny a shot there's some atheria there
oh yeah
Nell's monologue in the final episode
yeah that's a good call that actress is
terrific Wow look at that hair I love it
you look like Paul from Tekken Bride of
Frankenstein thank you agoraphobic
fanboy Bride of Frankenstein the monks
ain't legit dad knows that those
Frankenstein movies are good at that
the Bride of Frankenstein you know I
probably haven't effectively in a long
time so buy yourself a horror fishin on
it's like I know the the Frankenstein
pretty well and I know I've seen the
bride but I need to watch it for reals
it's been a while it's been so I was a
kid
Lana Pico in the chat hey Lana all
flowers for algernon good call we said
Flowers in the Attic well somebody else
said flowers Amber Jones spam in the
chat all right ooh Bing bongs final
scene and inside out have me tear up
oh wait did you say this earlier or did
somebody else someone else said it to
chase me look at the puppy in the Taco
Bell box caution contains oh my god look
at that puppy that Supes adorbs and I'm
gonna make y'all cry with my
abbreviations now doctor who made me cry
it's Y actually there was an episode we
reacted to the finale of the eccleston
season that's going up on patreon
tomorrow oh yeah oh yeah I saw it
because I have a computer over here over
like there and John was editing and I
looked over and all I see is my face
court oh yeah I was searching several
moments of like can I get a freeze-frame
with a good very obvious cry just
because I feel like those are some of
the best reaction moments and they're
the hardest to transpose into a
thumbnail sometimes when I when we cried
they're like with the lighting that we
have it can't really isn't yeah it's
like it's weird like it's like a real
sad part of narcissism when you're
trying to find that reaction zone yes
it's like so embarrassing if you're like
tell easily I'm trying to find this
moment like I cry here you can't really
tell him crying this is kind of sad that
I'm like it's sad and not or like a
moving sad way but it's sad that I'm
trying to like make people like be more
inclined of watches by looking at my sad
this is the reaction to pulled out of me
to my team you
it's not a big deal if someone gets a
notification they see like oh it's
probably a great reaction if they get
moved to tears here but if you walk in
on us doing it it's just depressing huge
filling in and not another motivating
way it's depressing in like it's like it
feels pathetic and the mo way of doing
it because you're just pouring over
yourself yeah a fun Ahmed who smonny we
got Cobra Kai season 2 over on the
patreon zero no $5 and it's yours
all episodes DCF Ron is back Ron 25.00
is 90 cf why I did see the original Live
Aid performance before but it was one of
the things where I didn't know thank you
for your super job by the way but where
I didn't knew everything leading up to
that I cannot he's saying like the
narrative structure and building up to
that being the big crescendo moment of I
have AIDS I'm going out with a bang even
though this is not how it happened in
real life I didn't get a soul after this
ghost but in terms of the context of the
storytelling
yeah like beautiful that moment is that
make sense okay some catharsis to be had
there I feel feels yeah all right where
we are we're everywhere and nowhere
oh my god are we almost there all right
guys gonna wrap this up very very soon
very soon but not before the final super
Jets Katy Orlando was dating mando and
then she had an affair with Marlon
Brando dude every one of these needs an
Eminem rap now lately thinking about
Katy
there's an old photo of my niece and I
um do you want to kidnap her do you want
to make your own daughter claim her as
your own I know I know how it goes I
think the only other emotional film was
Green Mile it's the only other film
urban emotional but every mile national
can't think of anything else
Green Mile 20 years ago
and yeah it's just those two especially
difficult since I saw by myself the
first time to VHS saves that old oh wow
remember though they would separate him
over to God yeah chasing chase Gardner
your your peep after my own heart crying
crying with your family at the grid
couldn't properly skip ahead at least
with laser dis you could skip ahead oh
really I still have yeah I never knows
there was no scene selection that that's
when DVDs were my that's what that's why
DVDs are mind-blowing you could go to
scenes the first DVD I ever got was um I
didn't get it was like my dad bought it
was the first DVD I was ever exposed to
was the Brett Ratner directed the comedy
money talk money saw Chris Tucker and
Charlie Sheen and then you went to the
scene selection and then the scenes were
moving so you could see what exact scene
it was hey Jasmine's back in the chat
what's up dear Amber Jones the terminal
there's some good tears to be had viktor
navorski all right Tom Hanks yo dude
dude dude Eric Horseman got a shot
around the corner that's the one thank
you for getting my back Eric you're so
sweet buddy look at that real region
that's a real real rejects tattoo real
real rejects had Eric Derrick Eric
horseman lyric with the horse in guys
you can hear us Gabriel I know you lyin
you can I know you're lyin god help me
I'm a thought let's do my sweet man man
oh I'm sorry buddy hi there we go got a
chat all right sneaking in with
sympathies for the ladies working
tonight but I am in fact non-binary also
I don't cry much at movies but detective
Pikachu got me was it the nostalgia
the nostalgia that got to you buddy or
was it or was it you know the prospect
that maybe justice Smith's dad would
just stay a Pikachu forever I wouldn't I
mean detective Pikachu didn't get me
emotional at all no I mean I was
enamored I was really wowed by the first
half of that a lot of fun like bubbly
but yeah well I'm glad you can show
expirience I'm glad that you were moved
I love your glasses I think we have the
same exact clock you will have wonderful
the glass is kind of sore although I
know the windswept quality of your hair
and the rosy color of your cheeks you
look very sweet and pleasant okay but
the next super Chad we got to be as
equally complimentary to on their
profile that's right all right we got to
do this up Wow your choice to pick
cowboy bebop cowboy is such a good
course with your anime taste spike
obvious movie but Titanic always makes
me cry you know unpopular opinion I
don't think they could have balanced on
that door in Titanic you're talking
about yeah the door there's evidence to
support that yeah and also has to dies
somebody just enlightened me on this he
needs Leo jack has to die for rose to
become fully realized
pixie dream boy I don't know my friend
who explained this to me can explain it
better than I can
James Cameron ever speak about that [ __ ]
I don't know but I heard a very
interesting dissertation about how if
you think you know Ripley is the only
good you know female heroine look at
Rose and then the last super chat of the
day oh my Mimi M you're the winner
congratulations she wants you to listen
to this oh I love Joyner Lucas oh man I
wish I reacted to it did you hear the
Will Smith rap I have not but I also
haven't heard the remix featuring real
Will Smith
yeah that's not talking about I haven't
heard either
at some time my god I'm just pressing so
many buttons I haven't heard either
version I would like to hear both of
them John you got the request thank you
me me anyway okay so we're saying sorry
by Joyner Lucas hired by are we talking
Nipsey Hussle right there and then
window okay Jake Cole alright alright
that's everyone for today I did it I'm
gonna take some a few weeks to catch up
alright guys three the last round of
comments that we got in chance iceberg
right ahead
Owen doesn't like tight end
Denzel curry let's see here Justin hey
don't freak happy to be here love
hanging with you too buddy it was a
great time thank you for the fun type
these wouldn't be fun without loss disco
movie magic I mean the only movie that
has ever made me cry was media because
it was so horrible oh I'm sorry to hear
that life Welles Oh
Manic Pixie okay yeah about Jack and
Titanic good night Mamie him anyhow like
me me I'm out of know your name guys we
got a shoot for if tomorrow we are going
to be putting up this video with where
we got an interview Leigh Whannell
director of Invisible Man and up gray
was also one of the people who wrote saw
and starred in it and he's done a bunch
of [ __ ] actually with James Wan worked
on the insidious films he's uh with
specs specs and the writer exactly and
then of course we we we interview Jason
Blum in there as well from Blum house
the man behind the Blum house named as
his house it's very short interview but
it was really fun to do and we've got
shoot a quick intro outro for right now
edit it and I'll be up tomorrow thank
you to everyone here you have a good
show ok alright you guys don't need a
fight appreciate everything you guys are
contributed so far check the discourse
is the mic drop and then thank you Thank
You Erik and Ryan for the last
contribution there but also yeah check
that video out tomorrow
a lot thank you everyone who was here
today have a good night stay tight do
the right thing no matter what life
brings no way just have a good rest of
yo day yeah thank you guys so much is a
lot of fun as usual love everyone here
see you next time be well party people
Cheers oh that's how I do it